they are remote and live in the densest
of jungle researchers and a film crew
spent weeks searching for them and
finally captured them on video they are
cross river gorillas the rarest of the
four subspecies of gorillas the Wildlife
Conservation Society says this is the
first professional footage ever recorded
of these primates in the wild listed as
critically endangered by IUCN Red List
the cross river gorilla numbers perhaps
fewer than 300 across its entire range
in Cameroon and Nigeria this video was
taken in Cameroon scag when a gorilla
sanctuary home to an estimated 16
gorillas researchers had staked out what
they believed were some favorite fig
trees of the gorillas and recorded them
some 30 to 40 feet up in the trees
feasting away through the years WCS
researchers have developed an effective
non-invasive monitoring system to keep
track of the gorillas without disturbing
them or getting them used to human
presence the gorillas are very wary of
humans WCS maintains that while many
gorillas are threatened by poachers
these gorillas in Kewanee have been
protected by the local belief that the
apes are people and therefore should not
be hunted or eaten but elsewhere the
cross river gorillas are threatened by
hunting as well as habitat destruction
it's hoped this new and rare video will
help raise awareness about this
little-known species and encourage
further protection efforts like the
creation of the cog when a sanctuary
which happened just last year